as a developer it can be difficult to
get started with new cloud technologies
whether you're looking to deploy a web
app set up a new database or run big
data workloads it's often challenging to
find the right materials to help you get
up and running
this is where google cloud quick starts
come into play
quick starts are quick step-by-step
tutorials to help you get started with
new google cloud products
they typically cover basic use cases
like how to make your first api call or
deploy your first hello world
application
quick starts can cover several different
ways of interacting with google cloud
products
first some quick start show you how to
get things done from the google cloud
console this is where you can manage
your cloud resources directly from a web
portal
you can do things like create new
compute engine virtual machine instances
set up new databases and check on the
status of deployed apps
you can also create new projects set up
billing and manage permissions
second there are quick starts to show
you how to use google cloud command line
tools like gcloud gsutil and bq
all of which are part of the google
cloud sdk gcloud is a command line tool
that allows you to do things like create
compute engine virtual machine instances
deploy web apps to app engine and set up
google kubernetes engine clusters
gsutil is the command line tool that
allows you to interact with cloud
storage you can do things like create
new buckets upload file objects and
download file objects
bq is a command line tool for
interacting with bigquery google cloud's
enterprise data warehouse designed to
help you ingest store analyze and
visualize big data and finally we have
quick search to show you how to interact
with google cloud via code using our
client libraries
these quick starts include instructions
and sample code for programming
languages like python node.js
go
java
ruby
php
c-sharp and c-plus plus
let's take a look at an example
quickstart for the cloud vision api
which provides you insights about your
images using the power of machine
learning
first there's the before you begin
section which shows you how to do common
tasks before you use any product such as
setting up a new project enabling
billing and managing authentication
next you'll learn how to install the
cloud vision api client library for the
programming language of your choice
and finally there are pieces of sample
code in different programming languages
to show you how to use the client
libraries to call the cloud vision api
via code
for python you can just copy and paste
this code into a new file called main.py
and run python main.py from your command
line interface
so where can you find these quickstart
tutorials you can find our full
collection of quick starts at
cloud.google.com
docs quick starts
quick starts are easy to find in our
product documentation
here in the cloud vision api
documentation there's a section in the
left navigation bar for quick start
tutorials
and finally we also have video versions
of these quick starts where we walk you
through how to get started with various
google cloud products
check out the links in the description
below
and there you have it quick starts are
easy to use tutorials that show you step
by step how to get started
make sure to click the like button and
subscribe to the channel for more
getting started content we're excited to
see what you build
[Music]
you